We Begin this morning with the legal
Jeopardy facing former president Donald
Trump attorney general Merritt Garland
has appointed a special counsel to
oversee criminal investigations
regarding the former president's records
held at Mar-A-Lago and his alleged
efforts to overturn the 2020 election
results Trump says he won't take part in
the investigation and slam the justice
department for what he described as
quote a never-ending Witch Hunt Natalie
bran is in our Washington Bureau with
the very latest Natalie good morning
good morning Michelle and CBS News has
learned this had been in discussion for
weeks at the justice department to
independently manage the investigation
the Attorney General calling the
circumstances here extraordinary
this is a rig deal former president
Donald Trump fired back Friday night
hours after attorney general Merrick
Garland named a special counsel to take
over the ongoing Department of Justice
probes into January 6 and the handling
of classified documents at Mar-A-Lago
I've been going through these
investigations and hoaxes and scams from
the day I came down the escalator at
Trump Tower the Attorney General cited
Trump's announcement this week to launch
a 2024 White House bid and President
Biden's intention to run for re-election
in his decision I have concluded that it
is in the public interest to appoint a
special counsel such an employee an
appointment underscores the Department's
commitment to both Independence and
accountability in particularly sensitive
matters tasked with the job Jack Smith a
career prosecutor since 1994 who most
recently served as the chief prosecutor
for the special Court in The Hague
investigating war crimes before that he
led the public Integrity section of the
justice department Jack Smith has built
the reputation as an impartial and
determined prosecutor this decision
takes a lot of the politics out of it it
also means that in all likelihood uh
these cases pick up urgency while the
last special counsel proven to Trump and
Russian interference in the 2016
presidential election lasted around two
years legal experts say this new
appointment could expedite these latest
investigations I suspect it means we'll
see a decision and potential indictment
within the first three months of the new
year
now attorney general Garland says he
will make sure the special counsel has
the resources he needs to carry out his
work quickly and completely meanwhile
the White House said it had no knowledge
of this announcement stressing the
independence of the justice department
Jeff
Natalie thank you very much